[Music]
hello
this is
wait for it
oh that was just an intro screen this is
an intro screen warning this game
contains scares sounds and loud screams
gore and blood
oh my god hi
geez from zas loud this is the smiling
man if that wasn't obvious
[Music]
cool
[Music]
i have a habit of leaving everything for
the night
yeah many say this is hobby of mine is
strange and then i decided to go
shopping at the market for dinner
at dawn but tonight i came face to face
with evil it was a horrible and scary
experience it was 2 a.m
these were a bunch of disjointed
sentences not all of them made a lot of
sense
go to the market
i see
he watches you all the time even at
bedtime
all the
time okay
what else does he do all the time at
bedtime all the time
why the hell do i live on this haunted
high
how are you you smiling you better not
be smiling you can attract the frowning
man
much scarier than you all right he's
just he's just grooving
he's just grooving
bothering nobody he's just grooving he's
having a good time why would i interrupt
that
why would i be worried about that i
shouldn't be worried about that in fact
i'm not worried about that or worried
about anything
okay
where's the market
where's the market
did i pass tomorrow i can't exactly call
oh no
oh
okay where's the market
is that the market
market
market market
okay i'm in the market hi
horus is that you
[Music]
hey what's up how are you doing
i see you have a tiny face
okay appreciate that
thank you
okay
i shopped at the market it was dollar
eighty-one cents okay
it's pretty cheap you think about it
oh oh god i'm too tired to run now
hey
what's up with you man
how many violins you got in those pants
oh too tired to run too tired for any of
this crap you cut that [ __ ] you cut it
out you cut that [ __ ] out
i'm going home
i'm going home because i can't deal with
you or that or any of the nonsense that
you're trying to sell me
so go away
man they need to put more lights on this
road
hi how are you doing hey man don't watch
out there's a crazy weird guy over that
way too many violins for his own good if
you know what i mean
all good here oh is that a paper
oh don't let their expressions fool you
their feelings and wants are different
you don't say actually i think their
feelings and wants are very apparent
just looking at that smile on that face
i know exactly what their feelings are
and what they want and um
i don't think it's going to be hard to
predict
i will kill you
i better not get too close to this
madman you say to me because i'm mad and
a man and i will mess you up if you come
near me hey
anyway stop watching me
neighbors
stupid the next night i made it to the
next night that is actually a surprise
i'm kind of shocked don't know how i did
that but i'm going to go to the market
apparently
what is it on this way oh i'm not too
tired to run
hey neighbor
oh oh
for space to skip well i could skip down
stroll no that's not good
ah
[Music]
can i help you
can i help you
can i help you
i don't want to seem rude and cross the
street but uh
i might might do that
try not to jostle all the violins in
your pants what was the deal
what the hell do you want
eh
okay
did i accidentally skip it i thought i
was trying to
did i did i lose out on some lore lixian
please find footage of someone else
playing this game and insert whatever i
missed if i missed anything thank you
and then here's my approval reaction to
that oh
you sly dog just put in whatever feels
appropriate
i'm gonna run now
i really gotta make it to the market or
else i'm not gonna be very happy
oh my god
i'm gonna make it to the market i think
[Applause]
market
i made it hi
i'll take the usual okay hey
yellow now take a bag of chips
one of these
take one of these
oh i'll look at you now
this isn't oh hey i thought that door
was uh closed
okay
am i dead bad ending
bad
i guess i got the bad ending
you need to explain yourself how there
was supposed to be a good ending to all
this was i supposed to find a gun
and shoot you in your smiling face
elixir and maybe find someone else
playing the bad ending and or the good
ending and play it here as well i'll
i'll apply the appropriate reactions
oh my god it was him all along oh wow
what a twist um what a satisfying
experience okay that'll do okay thank
you very good very spooky
moving on
welcome to
my
happy place
what
hello oh hi
hello
hello
hello this was made in the liminal space
jam
the liminal space game jam the liminal
space horror game jam
whatever that was
okay
i don't know why my happy places threw
up
what
through a yard of shipping containers
but
okay
so far i'm gonna give this like a 4.2 on
the liminality meter wait
sticking up little dial in the bottom
right this
liminality is increasing
what
oh
oh no
[Music]
we're like uh pushing 9.0 on the
liminality meter
so apparently just oh
hey what's going on over here hey okay
watch what what's up
okay all right that was a
that was a 9.8 on the liminality meter
the
you don't need to know
why
i don't need to know i don't need to
know
turns out i don't need to know
turns out i don't need to know
oh
i was waiting for you why
okay
hi
i don't feel very happy here i'm just
going to say that the hapidometer is uh
real low hitting the zero going into the
negatives
oh happy tomorrow
oh wow
i'm so happy
oh
okay
i've never seen any game do something
like that where it just stops
i'm just making a desire path straight
to the big black obelisk
or it's a censored object that i am not
allowed to see or show on youtube
okay i gotta follow the path all right
no no uh no desire path for me okay all
right i see i can't sprint so there's
gonna be a long road
to my happy place
it's like symbolic
with the thing that you
never mind all symbology gone
oh boy
oh
boy
[Music]
do i go in here
okay
[Music]
all right
god what if you looked up one day and
just saw a sky box i know what you did
what was that
did i just question the nature of my
reality like you saw the hard edges of a
skybox
[Music]
hi oh
[Music]
what
ladder
nope okay i guess i go towards the door
there
or there's a weird shadow figure
standing in front of it
are you guarding me from my happy place
[Music]
oh come on the atmosphere is fine
good
all right
the atmosphere is not fine in here
oh the atmosphere is very unfine
exit
yeah i don't believe you the eyes say
otherwise i'm gonna go here hey uh never
mind i'm under the eyes say please
they draw me in
do i really wanna go yeah kinda
oh
wow
oh
[Music]
oh hell yeah
i can't go on it
is that an exit sign up there how do i
get up there
oh
god
join me i'm home now where is home and
where is me and where are you
okay
oh no am i folding am i falling oh no
i'm falling
oh no i'm falling
okay well um
has it done
what
what
what
what what
okay i guess that's it i'm left with
more questions than i have answers and
the answers is zero but the liminality
meter is broken and the happy place
meter has dropped to nothing so i'm
neither happy but i am extremely liminal
thank you
moving on
whoa this is roma or what i imagine it
actually is it's tumor
like red rum but murder
destroy them all
what what am i oh
oh
oh
weird this is a strange point of view
i apologize if the controls seem a
little wibbly wobbly they're wibbly
wobbly for me too the field of view is
way cranked up
okay
well this is spooky
oh wait a minute
hey i've seen this before
i can't open that door
[Music]
oh different
you're knocked over
i see
so i need to destroy five of five
somethings oh
that's not good
[Music]
what's with the heartbeat
oh no
[Music]
what is that deal
sometimes you have to plunge into
darkness to get out of a closed loop
press f
i'm properly plunged
oh no
[Music]
interesante
what's with this place where my
flashlight only goes two feet in front
of me
oh never mind that wasn't me
oh
don't think i don't see how i'm gonna
destroy five or five somethings if i
can't even tell where i am or what i'm
doing
hello
okay
[Music]
hmm
okay
an elevator good that's progress
hopefully i'm going to be able to
destroy the thing
this why would you do that
okay
oh hi
hello
what's with you
what am i doing that's my question what
am i doing why did i just destroy that
thing
oh
[Music]
hi
watch out i'll destroy you
i will do it okay
okay
weird
very weird
okay i'm doing this now this makes total
sense
[Music]
i'll destroy you
it does not make sense you know what no
it don't
you know what noah don't the funny thing
is no it don't
it
it don't
it don't
plunge
oh my god
oh wow
frank
okay
hey frank
what's up frank
how you doing frank
okay
all right i'm gonna go for whatever's
screaming in the other room
[Music]
that's fun
i have to go towards you i die when will
it end
at five obviously
hello
hi
[Music]
well hello looks good
this looks great
this looks wonderful
okay
hi hello
how diddley
no
no
[Music]
yes that's what i'm looking for hey
i've been waiting for you
i don't want well we don't want anything
but we have so you got a deal
this is what it is and we're going to
deal with it
oh okay
is that what you think
so what you think you can do to me
is that what you think
i hear you
i'll find you
i know now that i'm the monster in here
you're afraid of me
oh god oh my god no thank you five of
five
yes i don't know
oh hello
hi
haven't i been here
oh
it's warm
oh it tingles
ah
oh
oh
there we go that was very spooky it was
definitely just because it was like a
different point of view i like the
on-demand changing location with the
flashlight and it got me with that jump
scare and i think the message is just
like a rumoured that's clearly tumor
backwards so it's like something about
fighting your inner demons in the battle
because cancer is very terrifying and
scary but very good i like that a lot it
was short sweet to the point nice and
spooky that's what i like at horror
games
[Music]
you